Ngoài nè mùa tăng năm 2020, các quan cạnh rất đợi trà công an tình phố đảnh nắm cho biết đã tạm giữ tệ sế và chủ sê linh quan đến vụ trẻ ô tổ tại kây sang Pé Chô Liên Mí số Chín Nguyễn Tung Tung Bí,
Sát Thân Dình, đảnh nắm, khiến hai người tử vòng. Lâm việc với các quan công an, tệ sế phó vễn dùi đồ khai nhận, dấu quá hoảng sợ li khu bếc cách sự chi, không một cử cử cơ nạn nhân.
Anh cho biết bản thân chỉ lần người lấy hộ, chủ sê lại anh ở規 vầy, chủ sát thân dình, chủ khu bý kinh xanh cho chủ trẻ em ở địa bản.
Mọi người anh về chỗ hai nạn nhân gia địa bản địa lần việc cho mình, một trong hai nạn nhân là em họ của anh vầy,
chương em một táng năm năm 2019, anh về uống biệt nên nhiều anh trở giúp, sợ đó, sự khu xế ra.
Châu khi đó, Mí nhân vụ trẻ được sất biển có linh quan đến hàng chủ khu bý bình và quy chữ trong khu xe.
Thế có quan công an, tại sế lần người lấy hộ cho chủ xe, số bình, á quy chình sẽ cũng không thuộc sự yếu của người này.
Tuy nhiên, tại sế và chủ xe đã vi phạm quy định về phòng trái, chủ trái và có thể sẽ bị sự lý hình dự.
Hình vẫn phòng các quan cạnh rất đều trạc công an thịt phố đảnh đăng tích tục phối hợp các đơn vịnh nghiệm vụ khám nghiệm phương tịch,
giảm định quy nhân trái nổ đông thư cung của hồ dơ, đều trà làm só vụ việt.